their Titans of the comic book movie
world but are Kevin feige and James Gunn
destined to be friends or foes DC
shocked Hollywood when they announced
that James Gunn and Peter saffron had
been tapped to lead DC Studios
overseeing film television and animation
for the comic book giant Gunn being one
of the few people to have worked with
both Marvel and DC is revered by comic
fans for his work on Guardians of the
Galaxy The Suicide Squad and Peacemaker
in a joint statement Gunn and saffron
said we're honored to be the stewards of
these DC characters we've loved since we
were children we're excited to
invigorate the theatrical experience
Around the World As We Tell some of the
biggest most beautiful and grandest
stories ever told hopefully Gunn will be
able to turn around the struggling DC
extended Universe which appears to have
been renamed the DC Universe when Gunn
posted the news to Twitter he was
inundated with congratulations from fans
and celebrities alike fans naturally
started making demands almost
immediately from from Justice League
sequels to poison ivy and Harley Quinn
romances and everything in between but
Gunn still has one foot in Marvel's door
even as he makes his move to DC so how
does the head of the MCU Kevin feige
feel about the announcement in an
interview with The Hollywood Reporter at
the premiere of black panther wakanda
forever Kevin feige commented on James
Gunn's Ascension to the head of DC
Studios unsurprisingly the MCU Czar had
nothing but kind things to say about
guns promotion and he insisted he's
still working closely with Gunn on the
MCU we have a wonderful thing called the
Guardians of Galaxy holiday special
coming out we have one thing called
guardians galaxy vol 3 coming out in May
feige also voiced some light-hearted
concern about gun scheduling
how we have any time to work on DC until
May I don't know but once he does have
the time I'll be very excited and first
in line feige and Gunn insist that there
is no rivalry between the two Studios
and the two seem to be as friendly as
they ever were but that hasn't stopped
fans on social media from pitting the
two Studio heads against each other one
Twitter user wrote Kevin feige
accidentally creating his own arch
nemesis is such a beautiful comic book
Arc others commended feige on his
professionalism in praising gun with one
tweeting Kevin feige might be one of my
favorite people ever it's so wholesome
to see him unconditionally be a Marvel
Studios alum's number one fan even if
it's for a rival Studio that being said
gun's relationship with Disney wasn't
always as peachy as it is now back in
2018 the company fired Gunn for some old
offensive tweets that were dug up by
conservatives angered by guns opposition
to Donald Trump the social media posts
were dug up by conservative media Outlet
The Daily Caller in response to Gunn's
outspoken criticism of the then
president the tweets and question were
posted in 2008 and 2009 Alan horn chair
of Walt Disney Studios at the time said
the offensive attitudes and statements
discovered on James Twitter feed are
indefensible and inconsistent with our
Studio's values and we have severed our
business relationship with him it's
worth noting that in a 2021 Interview
With The Hollywood Reporter Gunn said
that Horn's decision was as much of a
shock to Kevin feige as it was to
anybody else in a now deleted tweet Gunn
responded that in the early days of his
career he thought of himself as a
provocateur often telling jokes that
were outrageous and taboo he also
claimed to have grown as a person since
making those jokes according to deadline
the public apology that Gunn made and
his contrite attitude throughout the
whole process led to Marvel rehiring gun
horn met with gun on several occasions
to discuss the incident and seemed to
think that the director was truly sorry
for his tweets evidently Gunn seems to
have won fans trust over the years too
and most people seem to be perfectly
happy with his new position what his
promotion means for the DC you however
remains to be seen
[Music]